i must say your some of your tweets oh
lord
i can't i really can't even blame staff
those are my tweets yeah
right i mean look if people have called
me a potty mouth my whole life i've been
known to swear once again but i'm a
comic you know you're a congressman
i mean you respond hey some comics are
presence of countries right now that's
right
yeah
i'm doing quite well right
um
but like you responded to a russian but
i'm sorry you have me confused with some
other politician that gives a [ __ ] what
you think
[Applause]
i i'd like to point out i actually
edited that tweet to take at least one
swear word
give me some trouble here says ted cruz
you said you finally stand up to
somebody where was that spine when trump
went after your wife by the way your
balls aren't in a jar in cancun if
you're looking for them
[Applause]
[Laughter]
but it is very different from what we
used to see a
decorum from a politician and when trump
you know when trump talked like this you
know liberals he was all he was the bad
guy but
it's just the way people are now i mean
trust me i'm not again it well i would
say this like i don't go looking for
fights but i'm not afraid of a fight
right and every time someone is you know
if you see him ever acting on twitter or
anything else in life it's just someone
decided to come at me and i'm not that
type of person who just backs down i
mean you're the guy i've quoted you on
this show a number of times because
you've been talking about this term
latinx
which
sounds i don't know what it sounds like
it's something that white liberals made
up right it's something that's used
largely by white liberals and small
amount of latinos but largely is to
satisfy white liberals not necessarily
students now there are some people that
you said stop doing this because we have
polling on it and like an extraordinary
number sometimes up to 99
of latinos either don't know it or when
they hear it don't like it or offended
by it yeah right well it's just it's
think about this way like i i had a
little marketing firm when i was a
little uh way younger
if i was working for a firm and i said
i'm gonna use this term that only three
percent of the population identify with
and forty percent of the population hate
that firm would probably get rid of me
because like what are you doing how are
you actually reaching out to me why are
you even reaching out to people this way
for some reason the laws of gravity and
rationality have skipped when it comes
to latinos you know they're i'm being
told
you know a language that i had to you
know forget in order for me to learn
english spanish was actually my first
language and i was told to forget
spanish so i could learn english is
something that i did back in the day i
was made to be feeling embarrassed
because i spoke spanish i mean kids used
to make fun of me because i used to have
a spanish accent
and now
i'm being told that my language is wrong
and my
thinking about my language is wrong uh i
don't need to hear that i love my
culture my language is part of my
culture and i'm not going to have
someone change that
i respect
our respect and that's what
latinx offends you in that that's how it
offends me now if someone says to me
that's what i prefer
to be identified as i will do that
because i'm not an [ __ ]
right you tell me how you want to be
identified i will do that but just don't
throw this blanket on a culture that is
you know now longer than 600 years on
this continent that we somehow are wrong
because we have chosen to basically
stick to something that we've known for
600 years
[Applause]
don't you understand when white people
know what's better for you
what don't you forget about it
you